it's great to welcome to the program
today Jack still go who is associate
professor of Science and Technology
studies at University College London
where he studies the development of new
technologies in society one of which
Jack is of course autonomous vehicles
and and self-driving technology where
we've now seen a sort of longer period
of testing of different types by
different companies we've also seen some
tragic accidents including one
particular story involving an uber
vehicle in the United States which of
course we've spoken about let's maybe
start generally when you look at the way
in which self-driving autonomous
vehicles are being tested today
concerned pleased with the safety
measures that are being taken well
thanks for having me that'd be the first
thing to say our guess is that is that
testing on public roads of these new
technologies is necessary to an extent
because they simply will not be able to
learn to drive purely in simulation or
in test tracks and so there will be this
very difficult stage of engaging in a
form of experiment in public using the
roads as a laboratory of sorts getting
that right is extremely tricky I think
at the moment I am concerned because I
think we have a few players who see
themselves as being in a sort of race to
develop the technology first and I think
that creates incentives towards
recklessness which I think bodes ill for
the long-term success of the technology
and also as we've seen for for public
safety it may also force cities and
planners and and others into making bad
decisions about the technology unless
they're alert so we had the March 2018
uber incident where a pedestrian was
killed in Arizona it was a major major
story but one of the other stories
surrounding this is do we actually know
the full extent of what has had
during testing because some pretty good
investigative reporting is at least
suggesting that there are tests going on
sometimes with less than favorable
results which we simply don't know about
because it's not all being reported
do you believe that this is a concern
and what do you know about it well I
think I think it is a concern I think if
if I'm right and this is a form of
experiment and it's to an extent a
necessary experiment that at some point
these technologies will need to be
tested in the real world in the wild as
it were then the question is what does a
good experiment look like and I think
one of the things one of the the first
principles that we might apply I to to
testing is it for all pop makers to be
aware of what's going on so at the
moment we have a situation where each
company is in effect learning from its
own experiments and I think that's not
in the public interest I think if we can
find ways that companies can learn from
one another and that the public sector
can learns in the private sector and
that's probably the better way to to get
good outcomes what would you say are the
key technological problems that need to
be solved when it comes to the future of
these types of self-driving autonomous
vo-tech vehicle technologies well the I
mean the reason why they need to be they
need to be tested in in the wild is that
some of the problems that they will
encounter will be surprising ones so in
terms of the develop the necessary
development of the technology I mean we
shouldn't forget that it's technology
why I did it possible until relatively
recently and the reason why it is now
seen as likely that we will have you
know self-driving cars on our streets or
on the streets of some places within
within years is that there have been
dramatic improvements in in machine
learning which basically reduces the
problem of driving to one of image
recognition prediction and planning so
can can the sensors on the car recognize
the
around around it work out what bits of
that world's are going to do next and
then plan a safe route the technological
challenge there is absolutely vast and
in some places where it's being where
it's being tested and the technology
needs to improve only incrementally
because those places are relatively
straightforward places and you could say
you know there's a reason why they're
being tested in Tempe Arizona for
example because Tempe is a relatively
well organized city I'm here in central
London the prospect of a self-driving
car being able to navigate its way from
one corner of central London to the
other anytime soon is is far harder to
imagine yeah even here in Boston which
is generally speaking at a more London
like city in terms of the arrangement of
the streets the testing is almost
exclusively happening in what we call
the Seaport area which is much more like
Tempe that than it is like London so
that seems to be one issue another one
that comes up often is a sort of version
of the the infamous trolley problem the
idea of imagine a self-driving vehicle
hurdling towards a crosswalk for example
where pedestrians have entered and now
the vehicle has to sort of make a
decision as to whether it runs over five
people in the crosswalk or drives onto a
sidewalk and maybe only hits one person
but it's one person who is where cars
are not supposed to be is that actually
an issue that is going to be a
complicated one to solve or is that not
really one of the primary problems that
you identify in the way that the
configuration and algorithms will be
will be configured yeah I mean I think
the 20 problem is a distraction
I think the trolley problem you know we
should remember the origins of that
which is as a thought experiment in
applied ethics designed to demonstrate
the the insolubility of a particular
ethical dilemma right there is no there
is no ideal way to attempt to make a
choice in that
example applying it to self-driving cars
seems sort of interesting in a
dinner-party discussion type way in
policy terms it's irrelevant we it does
the technology too much credit it
presumes that the technology is going to
be able to be omniscient and able to
make calculations about numbers of
people and it also presumes something
rather troubling that we would want a
technology to make judgments among types
of people but I think thinking through
it and regarding it as a thought
experiment which is its proper status we
should take that and use it as a way to
to think about what there will be some
ethical dilemmas
Mindi uber crash has already revealed a
real ethical dilemma in technology
design which is the extent to which
engineers balance so-called false
positives against false negatives in the
way that they calibrate their algorithms
so that they don't get too jittery when
there is something fairly harmless in
their way but that they they do spot
something important and recognize that
it's something important when that thing
poses a poses a hazard
uber got that very publicly wrong in the
in March in that case that's a very real
ethical choice and it's that concerned
about rather than a trolley problem
which also you know suggests that the
morality here the responsibility sits
inside the Machine rather than with the
designers and developers of the machines
yeah I mean I think you could still say
of course it's ultimately how the
vehicle is programmed by the developers
and argue that it's it's still a
question but just one that the
developers have to solve but if we zoom
out a little bit
are you generally optimistic that these
problems are going to be solved and that
this is going to be a growing technology
sort of a growing reality of motor
vehicles in the world or do you think
that there's a chance that this doesn't
happen so I think I mean something
something will happen right I mean I did
so I'm a social scientist I don't make
prediction
about technology except that what I can
see here there is too much month being
invested for nothing to happen so I
think there are interesting questions
that relate less to when will this
happen and more to where it will happen
I think as we've discussed some places
like Tempe Arizona might be easy wins
for the industry it might be far harder
to see these things driving around you
know downtown Boston or Manhattan or
Rome or New Delhi anytime soon but I
think there's something else that isn't
being talked about which is the question
of what would it actually take to
realize the benefits that are being
suggested here and there I think we're
only hearing half a story at the moment
and you can imagine actually that if you
wanted to realize the benefits of
self-driving cars you would do some of
the things that town planners did with
the arrival of the Motor City in the
early 20th century which was to say okay
here's a beneficial technology in order
to make this safer we need to clear
other people off the streets it's not
normally talked about by self-driving
car developers but actually one way in
which you could make the system much
more controllable is by getting cars to
talk to each other and to infrastructure
and by segregating self-driving cars
into their into their own lanes it makes
a for a much more controlled system and
a much more a much easier engineering
challenge yeah and that gets to what
some believe will be really the danger
which is not the eventual end point
where most or all cars are autonomous
and they're interconnected but this
intermediate or transitionary phase
where you have human drivers who now
have to share the road with autonomous
vehicles and of course the autonomous
vehicles we have to share the road with
the human drivers is that transition
period and an area of significant
attention required um well yeah I mean
the transition period could be
never-ending I mean it's relatively easy
to imagine a world and
there are only self-driving cars yes
that it's much harder to imagine the
mixed world but we shouldn't forget that
you know we still haven't fully realized
the transition from horses to motorcars
there are still horses trotting around
on American and British roads so those
mixed systems happen and we've
introduced now other vehicles onto onto
our roads scooters bicycles various
other forms of mobility and that
transition will be difficult in that
difficulty policymakers will be faced
with some really difficult choices so
when American cities chose in effect to
privilege the motorcar over other forms
of transport and that had real effects
on pedestrians it had real effects on
public transit in the u.s. which in some
places has never quite recovered
I mean it's slightly easier here in here
in London because London is a city that
predates the motorcar so there will
there are still lots of parts of London
in which it isn't really really hard to
drive and much easier to to walk around
but for policy makers they're faced with
some very difficult choices about how to
manage that transition jack in the
limited time we have left is there an
income inequality angle to the
development of autonomous vehicle
technology so that's a great question
and it's one that not enough people are
asking the question in effect of who who
is likely actually to benefit from this
technology so before the technology is
really tried out it's very easy to for
the developers to say here is a
technology that is going to be
Emancipator it's going to allow people
who maybe can't afford a car or can't
drive a car because they are too young
too old maybe they're disabled maybe
they're blind and and it's gonna open up
mobility to those groups and it's very
easy to make those sorts of emancipatory
claims I would worry though that
development of this technology we
we'll be likely to just follow the money
all right so it is likely to be a
technology that is used by rich people
to do rich people's things in rich
places and if we are serious about you
know even the safety claims being made
for the for the technology a million
more than a million people abducted a
year die every die in car crashes and
most of those people are dying in the
poorest places in the world do we really
expect that a self-driving car is going
to be deployed in those places and able
to tackle that problem well I fear not
so I think the sooner we ask the
question who is likely to benefit the
the better we can make the decisions
about technology yeah extraordinarily
important angle and one that we think
about a lot when we talk about CRISPR
and genetic editing technologies very
very similar analysis exists there we
are speaking with Jack still go who's
associate professor of Science and
Technology studies at University College
London a jack really a pleasure speaking
to you today thank you so much it's
great to be here